we got a chance for Brenda to redeem
himself another name game last week
Oh tiramisu all these are shove over
here huh what's this emo Zac Effron got
for us
what's up Brendan and Theo got a name
game for you guys since none of you can
top each other with desserts or cheese's
why beat him in G how about some TV
shows bang bang
gus-gus we got that legacy flag up above
him all right what did you uh TV shows
there's billions Oh Emmy or a lot I
guess we're allowed to mispronounce them
I'm gonna go with in the heat of the
night mm you could use more of a little
show called friends obviously reading my
journal let me think about a good one
I'm gonna go with I will go with the
great show it is called you could go
just the 10 of us remember that old
television show I thought that would be
your first one for sure it's a good one
something feel doesn't believe in the
Big Bang
okay respect respect men true facts
facts all right I'm gonna go with the
television show here - in this
television show is gonna be call Modern
Family primetime ABC on the failure
Channel pam-pam - I'm gonna go with a
little show called Seinfeld recipes
Jerry Stiller Wow shut - Jerry Stiller
yeah that's a good call man I'm gonna go
with a famous show called my two dads a
popular good show that will only had two
seasons that a real show my two hands it
is right there
Wow look at it look at that geyser Paul
Reiser and that other guy right passed
away at this point
I do what those names Dick Butkus was a
legend bro uh Dick Butkus yeah well I
think Dick Butkus the famous football
player was in it
oh yeah Greg evigan apparently I using
yep Greg evigan okay Paul Reiser Oh
something that I believe called family
matters
oh then I'm in a full house he need me
Robbie uh noodle with an ax bro I don't
need a snorkel because I got the torkoal
son
you can find me in the Fresh Prince of
bel-air as a given right I think all
right I'm gonna roll with a really good
television show that people have seen on
television this show is gonna be called
The Price is Right game shows count that
might be what are we talking about that
might be a disqualification what yeah
Price is Right that one count is it
that's not a TV show
if we're going technicalities we might
have to go back to Big Bang Big Bang sir
well this the Big Bang Theory the
recently sets a TV show you're talking
game shows okay I don't know well I
don't know dude I mean TV show is TV
show yeah that's a game show what do you
think chin change the judge for name
game honestly when I first heard person
write I thought oh that's a game show
not a TV show yeah still TV show but not
in this particular moment this category
well that isn't making me sick you said
it is still a TV show first but it's not
like you said that there's so no I feel
good about saying it you knew you were
off done I knew that I knew I was like
okay well we're just gonna take this
into a different genre of TV shows
here's the thing I've seen it on a TV
yeah we're not watching on microwave
yeah but but then but then you could
call sports a basketball games a
football game yeah bowling day that's
silly first 48 it's almost like the
whole game is ridiculous we keep going
yeah the entire episodes me me name
names I can hit you with that Grey's
Anatomy oh I'll hit you with uh I'll go
with um
I'll go with that sweet show that
everybody likes Chicago Fire - Oh sugar
at the end of that I'll do that old but
dirty called coach Coach is good man and
that guy died too I think coach did know
he saw what are you talking okay coach
this show yeah okay thanks
all right I'll go with a really good
show that a lot of people don't think of
that often because they're not as smart
as me and that show is probably gonna be
call
[Music]
rescue 9-1-1 very good show all right
that's a new one right huh that's the
old one the original I'm gonna hit you
with that true detective seasons 1 & 2
what is streaming that's streaming XP oh
we're doing streaming well you did a
game [ __ ] I don't I love the
accounts alright are we still counting
prices right though
no no we can't play for those who like
cancel shows out there alright ok I saw
it can't be on per meter cable like a
movies fault I'm gonna say something to
this fella I think it off - with narcos
I'm gonna say this once radley this
shirtless boo radley was centered in
this video from obviously the inside of
his grandparents attic ok give us some
specific man TV shows you could say
acres of land we could do forever ok
don't use things that are green mom
these are green would be pretty good
actually better than TV shows would go
all [ __ ] yeah just forever man you know
fair fair enough fair enough
deserts was pretty open-ended and it was
it was a good time last week so it was
one game shows are fine I mean you've
you lost with a game show but it's
whatever well I mean and then you lost
also not with true detective that's a TV
it's just shun raining no it's not it's
on HBO
I don't have the HBO been around for
years man I think you guys are going on
you guys doing sitcoms like funny
sitcoms or stuff that we grew up okay so
yeah HBO's tagline is it's not TV it's
HBO I don't know if that comes yeah but
still not streaming yeah you're right
it's a TV show there are seasons yeah I
don't even know look I'm fine with I
blame it on this guy I'm part of that
all right gang
[Music]
King
[Music]